robot dinosaur attacks huge fancy
testicle fads New Jersey invasion
whatever he says South welcome back
finally to some more South Park if you
listen at all to what I say we I
couldn't finish this series until the
game was actually out and it's out now
so we can finally keep playing how
awesome is that hey hey so if you
remember where we left off we saved
Craig and we need to return to Cartman
to tell him that we recruit crude in all
our [ __ ] so let's do that shall we
hi gentlemen thanks to the new kid our
entire army is assembled it is my belief
that the new kid deserves to rank up in
level to honor his efforts he will no
longer be called douchebag new kid I
hereby dub thee sir douchebag
congratulations I just saw how it's in
pink thank you oh I got that take back
that which is rightfully ours a carrier
raven has come with news that the stick
of truth has not yet been taken to the
Elven forest it is in the possession of
the bard
five Oh God not the part the boat is a
level 10 drought who can use magic to
exchange and destroy enemies
no no are you ready to continue your
training then make haste to the training
grounds I wonder who the bard is how
long has those Jewish girls now it would
be so funny as long as I level up I
would start becoming more like a
traditional I'm going to teach you how
to use a ranged magic attack it's not
easy but being able to come a spell from
a distance can save you in battle
allow me to demonstrate yeah show you
one more time what nothing yeah you see
how it works
now you try way back from where you're
standing cut the magic throw down your
opponent this [ __ ] game man why I was
what a hell are you how does that even
yes yes but now let us see how you fare
against a real opponent
hey hey Maggie Maggie think could you
come hey Skye could you um spy with you
smack no man he's gonna try to move I'm
Josh
now just that coming down Kappa spell
early haha alright go back to use it
wisely in battle douchebag and never on
a man's pose
don't forget breads never fart on them
as balls if the carrier Ravens are
correct the bard is hiding out at the
end of the giggling donkey or a woman's
main let's find him before he's able to
take the stick back to the oven first
well huh but is doing the pelleting part
perfectly
oh cool so now we have a little bag you
better stock up like some pallets and
postings the end of the gathering donkey
is a dangerous place
that's all noggin you shut down your
meeting weapons Your Honor that's a
pretty take we're here here's what we
Shelly's a gay Celtic battle pain yeah I
just the items in this game is [ __ ]
hilarious jjk armor I don't know man
that's pretty good
hey let's buy this hey that's actually
better ok let's let's go with this there
it is the end of the giggling donkey
well tell him are you sure the bard is
hiding out in there that's what Twitter
says carrier raven butters sorry that's
what the carrier waving says Craig and
token guard the back door butters Kenny
sir juice bag let's go in sit
hey closer juice bag the end of the
giggling donkey harbors the scum abalzer
on a glass of middle rank is no meter
wide today only fair Yale a pint of
Ferriero then man Kenny looks hot today
has anyone seen the bard Nicki what cup
of Ferriero isn't much if not
accompanied by some Bartok poems and
songs sure he's here all right he's got
a room down in the cellar huh and I
shall pay handsomely for his services
sir dues back butters douchebag go down
in flush him out princess Kenny and I
would be waiting here to murder remember
the bard can use songs to enchance don't
let him get to you prema since Kenny's
so high so hot right now
oh uh it's books down here I don't know
what the hell he would be doing down
here is dark as [ __ ]
bad and sweaty oh there is oh I know who
is no no you should have never come here
humans I am a level 10 bar and with my
loot I shall power up my oven guards
with magical songs of Incheon
besides which a Meghna Magica songs have
been changing me me with magical sounds
with Chad Meghna magical sounds bikini
means okay okay hey Meghna magical song
seviche me me me with magical songs been
chair okay hey Meghna Magica song
ceviche me me me with magical songs been
chair hey hey Meghna magical songs been
changing me me with magical songs been
Cherokee Medan magical sounds been
changing me me me me yeah Bravo you did
it all by yourself yeah I went with the
maiden from stone baby she didn't talk
much but boy did she swallow
I actually wanted my closest friends
it started as a little bit I feel bad
for laughing but
okay let's let's now let's say that guy
actually you know I never show this guy
send a request for this one I just took
a galley from across the sea and boy am
I on site you never remember him wow
what a great battle
wow what a butt-kicking
big butter this is my favorite side
character but finish them up I will
protect this stick of truth ten is
funnier okay
that's a quick way to deal with them I
guess we'll have to fight these guys
wait how they're cool hmm I think I
could do something here shut up about us
no Alexia
okay I'll handle this okay did something
good oh my ankle I think it might be
broken
take a look come on what is this a
secret or something no I had to do it
okay but at least we got rid of that so
if you shoot them before the fight you
get a little advantage and then you
punch them so they're a little stunned
before it s alright let's finish this
guy out I upgraded this like a David
light so it's pretty overpowered you see
and butters has this attack which is
pretty awesome see I wish I could
upgrade it I don't know if I can up good
maybe I can well this guy's gonna have
to finish him off
yeah all right we're back Elvis shortbow
[ __ ] yeah we actually have a ballast
now while Axia blonde son of a [ __ ]
okay yeah we have them on gorian it's
not Mongolian it's Mangere is racist
okay thank you my wound is healed can
you give us upstairs
I think they locked us out I took my
courage on the levels well thief can't
take care of you guys go ahead come on
let's get out of here how does a level
system work in the root of life like it
doesn't make any [ __ ] sense
[ __ ] the kitchen I know Cod man that's
far enough
all right now we attack them so they're
both gross out and so we get to start
why not buy this
come on Singham damn it oh we got him
I hope they're just sleeping that's me
when I play pokemon can I heal it King
my lord
maybe let him suffer just a little bit
more I'm fool oh no I'm not dead you
can't leave me but I want this so bad
all right fine but us go ahead and heal
yes yeah yeah that got that ready bud
he's up in one of the rooms I catch it
oh they took princess kini took rips
tears I'm sure they're gonna rape her
don't let the bridges Keaney
the wizard King is done for take out the
new kid while I go upstairs make contact
with the King of Hell alright so after
playing the game a lot of hours I
realized blinking items you can shoot
and you can make the battle oh she has a
can mean online review there we go
now but can't say that yeah that's so
wrong man no [ __ ] you
what's your [ __ ] language Oh God
now Shetty's oh god what oh damn
okay no [ __ ] Taco Time maybe Taco Time
that's [ __ ] crazy okay whoa he took
away all my mana
we're gonna have to finish him first
this looks like a tough battle mine my
god damn he has so much help
I bought it now don't panic just drink
this water what the [ __ ] - where is it
there you shut up about it
my God we're so fun Oh No oh [ __ ] okay
we're still good we're still good we can
finish him it's so funny yeah we did it
okay so happy
he's over there he's hurt bad
good thing my medicine skills are plus
four will revive the lizard you guys get
upstairs man plus four that's pretty
good
oh my god we did about it sorry look at
this play we [ __ ] it up big time
oh come on wait a minute listen they're
raping the business right now okay I
don't know what they're doing but it
sounds like he likes it okay well that's
that makes sense am I supposed to do
something here alright that is blinking
they'll shoot that whoa whoa whoa whoa
and then I can shoot that
I find a ladder thingy right oh my god
the JDS and then I can good thing I'm a
[ __ ] genius look at this [ __ ] BAM
we can do well that's pretty epic man
haha my fair lady you must come with me
yes let's fire [ __ ] awesome I can't
get through the door appears to be
enchanted so I can't turn the dog you
can't hold the door not barred that's
cheating I have the stick of truth which
means I control universe and I say
holding the doorknob is okay huh
can he do that he has the stick of truth
he can do what he wants dammit he's got
to be another way into this room
Kenny is now your buddy hello Carmen all
right first of all we have upgrade sir
[ __ ] lips god damn this way to
popular man at the side that I have more
friends in this game than real life no
it's not okay I forgot to mention that
the school has gingers if you get if you
get bit you're already dead so don't
come back here and affect the rest of us
all right let's command Kenny yeah
those are some big ol bitties hey that
is so [ __ ] up man yeah princess gone
wild double D buddy Howard double D
whatever floats your boat Kenny I agree
Kenny kids are beautiful you've nowhere
to run Bard
give me the stick of truth take it from
me if you can visit King step forward
now and fulfill your duty and fulfill
your today step forward now and fulfill
your dick stick throw it now and fulfill
your day hippy step forward now and
fulfill your day
step forward now and fulfill your days
and stick forward now and fulfill your
destiny
you and your match for a Grand Wizard
the stick belongs with us and I shall
use every body power in my class to keep
it from you but you want to throw down
drop kicks ass douche bag who is
douchebag that sergers bag to you and
he's about to teach you some manners
bird [ __ ] yeah I'm gonna teach you some
manners one ring don't tell me oh of
course
rats with that yeah that's that's what I
thought whoa I got a new that I get
circumcised Johnny I'm ready all right
we're gonna have to get through those
first and by doing so I guess they don't
have a lot of health all the world's a
stage it's time you got your book yeah
they don't have a lot of help whatever
gets them away
oh nice that's pretty awesome how you go
Kenny use your charm on that sure I'm
your titties oh yeah so lucky but touch
it what
oh god yeah so much help alright and now
I guess finish I don't know
sorry princess Kenny gently now but
you're my mind you okay dammit Kenny
died those basics I don't know if we can
do this all by ourself
you through swine shagging swine Jagger
okay can we revive him no it's not dead
well where the [ __ ] is he
oh is that for one more round okay I got
it all right let's just keep a matching
then I guess
oh let's use circumcised Oh tiny little
knife okay that's that's [ __ ] up man
that's really fun
so you didn't actually die huh
interesting
shagging Oh God hey [ __ ] that what is
this what is he doing what is that oh
god no oh yeah the brownout
you've raised remember I think they take
a [ __ ] every time they hear the note or
something okay Kenny needs to shut up
Kenny yeah all right that's fun I like I
like that bus better crutch of weak no I
can't take his car but thanks so me well
it does do more damage hope you bros
enjoyed watching that would be a great
time to leave a like if you did I really
appreciate it I'll try to make these
episodes extra long for you bros and
gonna keep them daily so let's keep this
going and it'll be a lot of fun
I'll see mr buzz love you